Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
Marvel continues its tradition of teasing
us upcoming movies in the MCU with two extra
scenes in Doctor Strange's credits.
In this video, I'm going to break down the
movie's mid-credits scene and explain some
of its easter eggs.
And just to be very clear, there are spoilers
for both Doctor Strange itself and an upcoming
Marvel movie in this video.
So, if you want to avoid those, you can watch
my spoiler-free review of Doctor Strange here,
and come back and watch this video after you've
seen the movie!
OK, after the initial fancy set of credits
roll, we get a funny scene between Doctor
Strange and Thor who are sitting in Strange's
Sanctum Sanctorum in New York.
Thor comments that Earth now has wizards.
Strange then offers Thor a cup of tea, but
Thor refuses saying he doesn't drink tea,
and Strange magically makes a very large glass
of beer appear instead!
This moment is a nice callback to the scene
in the first Thor movie where the Asgardian
god and Erik Selvig drink a boilermaker in
a bar from a similar sized glass.
And, of course, we also know from that movie
that it's coffee that Thor likes, not tea.
But what is Thor doing with Doctor Strange
here?
Well, if you think back to the last time we
saw Thor, it was at the end of Avengers: Age
of Ultron when he left the Avengers saying
he was going back to Asgard to investigate
the visions he had of the Infinity Stones.
Well, it's likely that Thor heard about what
Strange did in this movie and might even be
aware that he has access to the Time Stone.
This meeting between the two characters links
to the Thor: Ragnarok set photo that was tweeted
showing Chris Hemsworth holding up a card
that reads "177A Bleecker Street" which is
the address of Doctor Strange's Sanctum Santorum.
So, back to the mid-credits scene, Strange
explains to Thor that he keeps a watch-list
of individuals and beings from other realms
that could be a threat to Earth, and he points
out that Thor's brother Loki is on that list,
and Thor agrees that Loki is indeed a worthy
inclusion on the list.
Something of course we know ourselves from
all the shenanigans Loki's got up to so far,
particularly the events of the Avengers movie
Strange then asks, "why bring [Loki] to New
York?", to which Thor replies that he and
Loki are looking for their father Odin.
Strange asks Thor if they find Odin, whether
they'll all return to Asgard promptly.
Thor agrees that they will, so Strange confirms
he'll help him.
To understand this scene best we need to roll
back to the events of Thor: The Dark World
and remember that at the very end of that
movie, Loki has taken over the throne in Asgard,
masquerading as Odin.
Since that film, even though Thor appeared
in Age of Ultron, it still hasn't been revealed
that Thor knows what Loki has been up to,
even though we the audience do know.
Which suggests that this mid-credits scene
is a snippet of a scene from Thor: Ragnarok
rather than a separate stand-alone scene shot
just for the Doctor Strange movie.
After all, this scene was filmed by Ragnarok
director Taika Waititi, rather than Doctor
Strange director Scott Derrickson.
I think the last time this happened was with
the post-credits scene for Ant-Man which teased
a short clip with Bucky, Captain America and
Falcon from Captain America: Civil War.
All of this means that it looks like Thor
is going to uncover Loki's ruse back on Asgard
early on in Thor: Ragnarok and that they will
then team up with Doctor Strange to search
for the missing Odin.
And it also confirms that as well as Doctor
Strange appearing in Avengers: Infinity War
in 2018, we'll be seeing Benedict Cumberbatch
back in another Marvel movie in 2017.
So, that was the mid-credits scene from Doctor
Strange, which I thought was good fun and
a nice tease for 2017's Thor movie.
I especially liked the way Thor's beer glass
kept filling up by magic with more beer!
Must get myself one of those glasses!
But now, I'd love to know what you think about
Doctor Strange teaming up with Thor next year
in Ragnarok?
And let me know if you've got any predictions
about what we'll see them get up to.
And don't forget there is a second post-credits
scene too which I'm going to discuss in this
video here and I've also got a giveaway for
this cool book about Marvel's Doctor Strange
coming very shortly so make sure you're subscribed
and you've got your notifications turned on
for Flicks And The City.
You can also check out my full Doctor Strange
playlist which includes videos on all the
easter eggs in Doctor Strange, my movie review
and cast interviews.
Click on any of the links below to see those.
If you enjoyed this, don't forget to subscribe,
share and like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!